[Applause]
let's see what made
drew's news mood board
first in a new piece on vogue.com
young a young millennial writer says she
got a landline
and it changed her life yeah
the essay covers all the benefits
landlines are great for
working from home they work in an
emergency except for mine who's attached
to cable so when the power goes out it
all goes out
and they give your sweet little peepers
a break from that cell phone that you
just can't stop staring at
okay now for those young people watching
at home who think
what is this this is a telephone and i'm
here to show you how it's done
first you pick up the receiver
ah that's right that's this part right
here
and then you think of your besties phone
number which you have
saved in your mind
it's seven digits if they're local
11 if they're in a different area code
310.
now in the 917 i'd 212. oh yeah 212.
that's a hot
area code while the other side rings
you can fiddle with this curly thing we
call a cord
and then your bestie picks up and you
talk about boys and
girls and life and it's like the best
the thing of beauty and i'm so glad that
they're making comeback by the way this
is my personal
phone from my bedroom
there are two stories that i love to
follow
um two sites excuse me one is tank's
good news and he'll be here on the show
with us this month and another is
upworthy and if you're not following
either of these sites trust me i really
believe
that they will make your life happier
okay so go to our website and i'll link
you to both of them
so i saw this post on upworthy and it
gave a
it gave a woman oh that's what it is a
woman
she gave like serious thought to her
linkedin profile
lauren g saw her perfectly polished
power pose
and it didn't and she didn't feel like
it portrayed who she really was and so
to show some authenticity she replaced
it with a less professional one
and put up a much more real pick of a
mom balancing
everything in her life lauren i think
you really represent how
a lot of people feel this year okay
let's lift up the veil get rid of the
veneer
and proudly be our authentic self
thank you warren g i know i
love this oh time for a beauty junkie
alert
so guess what it's official banana clips
are back okay yeah the new york post
reports that the banana clip
has seen increased interest and getting
googled and pinned more than ever
how scary that they know that it might
not seem well worthy but just check out
this hairstyle kristen bell rocked with
this bad boy
yeah i think that's super foxy banana
clips are well worthy
oh and speaking of bananas we had to say
goodbye to carol baskin
the cat queen herself on dancing with
the stars
she gave it her all though and for her
last dance she performed the samba to
the circle of life dressed as
as a lion because of course you know
carol baskin lion so so long for now
you cool cat and kitten oh my god by the
way if you need
more tiger king because everybody does
check out the documentary special on the
channel
investigation discovery it just came out
this week
get it while it's hot
you